THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS WILL NOW COME TO
ORDER. SO GOOD AFTERNOON. MY
NOTES SAY GOOD MORNING, BUT
OBVIOUSLY IT'S NOT MORNING, BUT
GOOD AFTERNOON, EVERYONE. WE'RE
HAPPY YOU'RE HERE TODAY. TODAY
WE ARE HOLDING OUR HEARING HERE
IN ROOM 2200 OF THE Þ STREET
BUILDING. AND WE'RE ALSO LIVE
STREAMING THE HEARING. SO
MEMBERS OF THE PUBLIC, SENATORS
AND ASSEMBLY MEMBERS AND STAFF
HAVE THE OPTION TO BE HERE IN
PERSON OR TO FOLLOW ALONG FROM A
DISTANCE. AS A REMINDER TO
EVERYONE, TODAY'S HEARING
CONSISTS ONLY OF ITEMS THAT ARE
ON THE SUSPENSE FILE. ALL OF
THESE MEASURES HAVE ALREADY HAD
A HEARING BY THIS COMMITTEE WITH
AN OPPORTUNITY FOR PUBLIC
TESTIMONY. AS NOTED IN THE DAILY
FILE, THE SUSPENSE FILE HEARING
IS A VOTE ONLY HEARING WITH NO
TESTIMONY. SO I WANT TO BE SURE
TO THANK EVERYONE WHO
PARTICIPATED PREVIOUSLY DURING
THE PUBLIC COMMENT PERIOD. YOUR
INPUT WAS GREATLY APPRECIATED,
AND WE REALLY APPRECIATE YOU
PARTICIPATING IN, IN THE
DEMOCRATIC PROCESS. I WOULD ALSO
LIKE TO THANK MY FELLOW MEMBERS
AND THEIR STAFF FOR THEIR
ENGAGEMENT THROUGHOUT THIS YEAR.
SOUNDS LIKE AN END OF THE
SESSION KIND OF PRESENTATION.
AND IT IS BECAUSE THIS IS OUR
LAST APPROPS HEARING. I WOULD
ALSO LIKE TO TAKE THE TIME TO
ACKNOWLEDGE AND THANK THE
COMMITTEE STAFF WHO HAVE DONE
REALLY INCREDIBLE WORK UNDER
REALLY TIGHT TIMELINES, AND THEY
WORKED LITERALLY AROUND THE
CLOCK TO ENSURE WE COMPLETE THIS
PORTION OF THE LEGISLATIVE
PROCESS. LET ME MAKE SURE TO
THANK MY PERSONAL STAFF FOR
THEIR WORK AND EFFORTS TO ALSO
ENSURE WE COMPLETE THIS PORTION
OF THE LEGISLATIVE PROCESS,
NOTHING HAPPENS WITHOUT STAFF
BEING THERE AND TAKING CARE OF
THE QUESTIONS AND THE ISSUES
THAT THAT WE'RE DEALING WITH.
AND SO THE STAFF HAVE DONE A
TREMENDOUS JOB. I ALSO WANT TO
MAKE SURE TO THANK VICE CHAIR
SENATOR JONES AND HIS FISCAL
CONSULTANTS FOR BEING GOOD
PARTNERS IN THE PROCESS. THESE
COLLECTIVE EFFORTS HELP MAKE THE
CALIFORNIA LEGISLATURE WORK IN A
FRUITFUL AND A REALLY PRODUCTIVE
MANNER. SO BEFORE WE COMMENCE,
I'D LIKE TO MAKE A FEW BRIEF
ANNOUNCEMENTS ABOUT HOW WE WILL
PROCEED SO THAT THE PUBLIC,
MEMBERS OF THE LEGISLATURE AND
THE STAFF CAN FOLLOW ALONG. WE
WILL BE MOVING QUICKLY THROUGH
THE AGENDA ALPHABETICALLY, IN
AUTHOR ORDER. SO YOU'RE GOING TO
NEED TO PAY CLOSE ATTENTION AS
WE WILL ONLY BE ADDRESSING
MEASURES THAT WILL BE UP FOR A
VOTE THIS MORNING. IF YOU DON'T
HEAR ME, TAKE UP A PARTICULAR
MEASURE. THAT BILL IS HELD UNDER
SUBMISSION. AS WE GO THROUGH THE
AGENDA. I WILL ANNOUNCE THE
AUTHOR MEASURE NUMBER AND
PROVIDE A BRIEF DESCRIPTION OF
ANY AMENDMENTS TO THE MEASURE
BEFORE WE TAKE THE VOTE.
FOLLOWING THE HEARING, WE WILL
BE POSTING THE HEARING RESULTS
AND THE ACTIONS TAKEN ON EACH
MEASURE ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE AT W, WW, DOT SAPR DOT
SENATE DOT C.GOV. IN ADDITION,
FOR ANY BILLS THAT ARE BEING
AMENDED TODAY, WE WILL BE
HOSTING AN ADDENDUM ANALYSIS
WHICH INCLUDES A SUMMARY OF THE
AMENDMENTS AND THE REVISED
PHYSICAL FISCAL IMPACTS OF THE
BILL. THESE SHOULD BE AVAILABLE
ONLINE WITHIN AN HOUR OF THE
HEARING'S CONCLUSION. SO AS YOU
CAN SEE, IT'S BEEN A, THERE'S A
LOT OF WORK AND STAFF HAS DONE A
REALLY TREMENDOUS JOB GETTING US
READY FOR TODAY SO THAT WE COULD
GO THROUGH THE 515 BILLS THAT
CAME OVER FROM THE ASSEMBLY.
AND, AND DO IT IN A WAY THAT
ALLOWS PEOPLE TO FOLLOW ALONG
FROM THEIR OFFICES. SO UNLESS
ANYBODY HAS ANY QUESTIONS,
COMMENTS, CONCERNS OR WOULD LIKE
TO SING OR SOMETHING, WE'RE
GOING TO BEGIN THE BILL HEARING
MAYBE A TRIVIA NØ. SO WE NEED TO
ESTABLISH A QUORUM. MADAM
SECRETARY, PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. HERE. CABALLERO.
HERE. JONES I'M HERE. JONES.
HERE. ASHBY. HERE. ASHBY. HERE
BECKER. HERE. BECKER. HERE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. HERE.
CIERTO. CIERTO. HERE. WAHAB.
WAHAB. HERE. WE HAVE A QUORUM.
AND I WANT TO THANK EVERYBODY
FOR BEING HERE. BECAUSE WE'RE
READY TO ROLL. SO WE'RE GOING TO
START WITH, ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ADDIS AND HER HER FIRST BILL IS
AB 1885. THE STUDENT SUCCESS
COMPLETION GRANT PROGRAM. THE
MOTION, THE ACTION IS Dð. PASS.
ROLL CALL. VOTE PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. JONES. AYE. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE.
7 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. 7 TO
0. MOVING ON TO AB 1905. PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
EMPLOYEE RETREAT. RETREAT
RIGHTS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASSES
AMENDED PER AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. WE ARE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
AB 1885. WITHOUT OBJECTION, THAT
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 20 2022 MOBILE
HOME PARKS EMERGENCY
PREPAREDNESS. MOTION ON THIS IS
DUE PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL.
VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. NØ. JONES. NÓ. ASHBY AYE.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I CIERTO.
CIERTO. NÓ WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 5
TO 2. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 2.
AB 2295. CHILD SEX CRIMES.
STATUTE OF LIMITATIONS THAT ACT.
THE ACTION IS DUE. PASS AS
AMENDED TO MODIFY THE STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885, WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2537 OFFSHORE WIND
DEVELOPMENT. COMMUNITY CAPACITY.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
MODIFY THE GRANT PROGRAM
ELIGIBILITY APPLICATION
REQUIREMENTS AND FUNDING. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2022. WITHOUT
OBJECTION, THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 3233 OIL AND GAS
OPERATIONS. LOCAL AUTHORITY. THE
ACTION IS Dð. PASS. ROLL CALL.
VOTE. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. I BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
CIERTO NO. CIERTO. NO. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 2. THAT BILL IS
OUT. 5 TO 2. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER AGUILAR. CURRY
TOOK UP HER FIRST BILL. AB 457
BEVERAGE CONTAINER CRV. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. WITHOUT OBJECTION THAT
BILL. THIS BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL OF 7 TO 0.
AB 863 CARPET AND FLOORING
RECYCLING Dð PASSES AMENDED TO
ALLOW THE CURRENT PROGRAM TO
CONTINUE. AMONG OTHER THINGS,
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. NO. ASHBY AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0. AB 2237.
CHILDREN'S MENTAL HEALTH. THE
ACTION IS Dð. PASS WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
FOR FROM AB 1885. WITHOUT
OBJECTION. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL OF 7 TO 0.
AB 2286 AUTONOMOUS VEHICLES. THE
MOTION IS DUE. PASS. PLEASE CALL
THE ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. JONES.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO WAHAB.
AYE. WAHAB. AYE 6 TO 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 6 TO 0. AB 2514.
ORGANIC WASTE DIVERSION. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO STRIKE SOME
CONSULTATION REQUIREMENTS. AMEND
TO CLARIFY ELIGIBILITY FOR CAL
RECYCLE GRANT PROGRAMS AS
SPECIFIED NGUYEN TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM FROM AB 1885
AND WITHOUT OBJECTION, THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2703 MEDI-CAL CLINICS.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED PER AUTHOR, TO INCLUDE
ASSOCIATE PROFESSIONAL CLINICAL
COUNSELORS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THIS BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
WITHOUT OBJECTION, AB 2901
SCHOOL EMPLOYEES PAID PARENTAL
LEAVE. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
AND MAKE CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AND FINALLY, AB 3203
CRAFT DISTILLERS DIRECT SHIP
SHIPPING. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
ALANIS. AB 1817 HOMELESS YOUTH
IS A SUBJECT. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR TO
MAKE TECHNICAL CHANGES. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB.
1859 CORONER'S XYLAZINE
OVERDOSES. THE ACTION IS DUE.
PASSES AMENDED TO MAKE THE BILL
PERMISSIVE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ALVAREZ. AB 1005 IN-HOME
SUPPORT SERVICES. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS. NGUYEN SUBSTITUTE. A
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 1472 NATIONAL, CITY AND
IMPERIAL BEACH RV PARKS. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF FIVE TO TWO, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. ALVAREZ.
AB 2326. POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. ANTI-DISCRIMINATION
COMPLIANCE Dð PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO REMOVE
COMPLIANCE REVIEW REQUIREMENTS
AND ADDRESS CHAPTER ISSUES.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885 SO THAT
THE BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB 2501 WATER
QUALITY CONTROL PLANS, DONATIONS
AND GRANTS. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2586 PUBLIC POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. STUDENT EMPLOYMENT.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED
PER AUTHOR. TO ADD COAUTHORS
THAT WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FOR FROM AB 2022.
THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING
NO. AB 2783 SAN DIEGO UNIFIED
PORT DISTRICTS. THE ACTION IS
DUE PASS, AS AMENDED PER AUTHOR,
TO DELETE MARITIME INDUSTRIAL
IMPACT FUND PROVISIONS AND MAKE
CHANGES REGARDING BOARD
GOVERNANCE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AND FINALLY, AB 2996,
THE CALIFORNIA FAIR PLAN
ASSOCIATION. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885, SO THAT THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ARAMBULA. THE FIRST IS AB
805, WHICH IS SEWER SERVICE
DISADVANTAGED COMMUNITIES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS NGUYEN TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885, SO THAT THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
1840 THE CALIFORNIA DREAM FOR
ALL PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED PER PER THE
AUTHOR TO CHANGE SPECIFIC
PROGRAM REFERENCE. REFERENCES
AND DELETE PROVISIONS
ESTABLISHING A NEW SUBACCOUNT
NGUYEN TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 1888
LABOR TRAFFICKING UNIT. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2080 èC SCHOOLS OF MEDICINE
ENROLLMENT DATA. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2240. FARM LABOR CENTERS.
MIGRATORY AGRICULTURAL WORKERS
MOTION IS DUE PASS. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL. VOTE CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. NO.
JONES. NO. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO. CIERTO.
NO. WAHAB. NO. WAHAB. NO. 4 TO
3. THAT BILL IS OUT. 4 TO 3. AB
2795. CALWORKS INDIAN HEALTH
CLINIC PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR,
TO REVISE PROGRAM REQUIREMENTS.
THIS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER DOCTOR BAINS. AB 1122
COMMERCIAL HARBOR CRAFT MOTION.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS. THE SUB.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2357 èC SCHOOL OF
MEDICINE IN KERN COUNTY. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THAT
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2376. CHEMICAL
DEPENDENCY RECOVERY. HOSPITALS.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BAUER. KHN AB 460. WATER RIGHTS
AND USAGE. CIVIL PENALTIES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO
DELAY THE START DATE. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. NO.
JONES. NO. ASHBY HI. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
CIERTO. I. WAHAB AYE. WAHAB.
AYE. 6 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT. 6
TO 1. AB 1836 DIGITAL REPLICAS.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
REVISE A DEFINITION AND ROLL
CALL. I'M SORRY. AND ALLOW
CERTAIN ENTITIES TO BRING A
CAUSE OF ACTION AS SPECIFIED.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. JONES.
NO. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. CIERTO. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 5
TO 1. 5 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT.
2085. PLANNING AND ZONING.
COMMUNITY CLINICS. THE ACTION IS
DUE. PASS. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2099
REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH SERVICES.
THE ACTION IS TO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2236 REUSABLE
GROCERY BAGS. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB
2467 HEALTH COVERAGE. MENOPAUSE.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL. VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. ASHBY.
AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
CIERTO WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 5 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0. AB
2527. INCARCERATION. PREGNANT
PERSONS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
MAKE CHANGES REGARDING THE USE
OF RESTRICTIVE HOUSING, HOUSING
AND AMEND TO NARROW THE SCOPE
THAT THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. I CIERTO. AYE. CIERTO.
AYE. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 6 TO 0.
6 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. 2930.
AUTOMATED DECISION TOOLS. THE
ACTION IS Dð. PASSES AMENDED TO
DELETE ALL REQUIREMENTS FOR
STATE AND LOCAL AGENCIES TO
PROVIDE FOR ENFORCEMENT BY THE
CIVIL RIGHTS DIVISION ONLY, AND
TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE BILL
TO EMPLOYMENT. THIS IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. NO.
JONES. NO. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
CIERTO. NO. CIERTO. NO. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE. 4 TO 2. 4 TO 2. THAT
BILL IS OUT. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER. BENNETT AB 551
CPUC TRANSMISSION PLANNING. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED PER
PER THE AUTHOR TO REQUIRE THAT
GUIDELINES PREVAIL IN CASES OF
INCONSISTENCY. THIS WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2313 REGIONAL FARMER EQUIPMENT
AND COOPERATIVE RESOURCES
ASSISTANCE PILOT PROGRAM. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. AMEND TO MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON VOTER APPROVAL
OF PROPOSITION FOUR. IN THE
NOVEMBER 2024 GENERAL ELECTION.
BÀN A SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL
FOR FROM A IT IS AB 2022. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
AB 3162, WHICH IS OCTOPUS
AQUACULTURE. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS. SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
YOU ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. OKAY. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERMAN. WE'LL START WITH
AB 1831 CHILD. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASSES AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR,
TO MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES. THEN
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. 1937 STATE PARKS. FEDERAL
POINT. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
CLARIFY THE PROPERTY VALUE FOR
PURPOSES OF THE TRANSFER TO DPR.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL. VOTE. VOTE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. I. BECKER. AYE BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO WAHAB.
WAHAB AYE. 5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS
OUT. 5 TO 0. AB 1963. REVENGE
I'M SORRY. AB 1962. REVENGE. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2057 ASSOCIATE DEGREE FOR
TRANSFER COMMITTEE. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REDUCE THE SCOPE.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2458 POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. PARENT STUDENT.
PARENTS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
UTILIZE AN EXISTING DATA SYSTEM.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM FROM AB 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2511 BCP MARKET
DEVELOPMENT PAYMENTS. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885, THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0 EIGHT AB 2642. ELECTIONS
INTIMIDATION. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB
2655 DEFENDING DEMOCRACY FROM
DEEP FAKE DECEPTION ACTS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO NARROW THE SCOPE AND
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE
UP A COMMITTEE VOTES UNDER
ASSEMBLYMEMBER BERMAN AND THAT'S
AB 20. I'M SORRY, AB 3251. THE
BOARD OF ACCOUNTANCY. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS BÀN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 3252, WHICH IS THE
COURT REPORTERS BOARD. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS WITH A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THAT BILL IS OUT. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 3253, WHICH IS THE
BOARD FOR PROFESSIONAL
ENGINEERS, LAND SURVEYORS AND
GEOLOGISTS. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885, SO THAT THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 3254. CEMETERY AND
FUNERAL BUREAU. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REVISE CEMETERY
ENDOWMENT CARE FUND
REQUIREMENTS. THE WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885 SO THAT THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND
THE FINAL IS AB 3255, WHICH IS
THE BOARD OF VOCATIONAL NURSING
AND PSYCHIATRIC TECHNICIANS
TECHNICIANS. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR,
TO MAKE TECHNICAL AND CONFORMING
CHANGES. AND ON THIS ONE, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885 SO THAT THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BERNER. THE FIRST ITEM IS
AB 1992, WHICH IS BLUE CARBON
DEMONSTRATION PROJECTS. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO INCLUDE INLAND WETLANDS AND
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022 SO THAT THE BILL IS OUT
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2564
SENIOR CITIZENS AND DISABLED
CITIZENS. PROPERTY TAX
POSTPONEMENT FUND. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS. SO WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND AB
2666. PUBLIC UTILITIES RATE OF
RETURN. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. NOW WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER BONTA. WE'LL START WITH
AB 846. THE SUBJECT IS LOW
INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT, RENT
CAPS, AND THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
ALLOW DIFFERENT RENT SCHEDULES
FOR 100% AFFORDABLE HOUSING
UNITS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
BONTA AB 1186 JUVENILES.
RESTITUTION. THE MOTION IS DUE
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB
1975 MEDI-CAL MEDICALLY
SUPPORTIVE FOOD AND NUTRITION.
WHEN THE ACTION IS DUE, PASS AS
AMENDED TO DELETE DEFINITIONS.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT. 20. AB 2020.
THE SUBJECT IS SURVIVORS OF
HUMAN TRAFFICKING SUPPORT ACT.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO ADD A
COAUTHOR AND A STRIKE.
PROVISIONS RELATED TO SURVIVOR
REVIEW BOARDS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2381 CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2381 CALIFORNIA STATE PRESCHOOL
PROGRAMS. REIMBURSEMENT RATES.
DIDN'T I JUST DO THAT? OKAY
THANK YOU. CHECKING TO SEE IF
ANYBODY IS AWAKE. AB 2786 MOBILE
FARMERS MARKETS. THE ACTION IS
DUE PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REVISE REQUIREMENTS
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2851 METAL SHREDDING FACILITIES.
THE MOTION. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 3161
HEALTH FACILITIES, PATIENT
SAFETY AND ANTIDISCRIMINATION.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR TO ADD
CLARIFYING INTENT LANGUAGE. WHEN
A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885, THE BILL IS OUT ON A ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
BRYAN, WE'LL START WITH AB 544
VOTING. COUNTY JAILS. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2716 OIL AND GAS
LOW PRODUCTION WELLS. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR. TO NARROW THE SCOPE, THE
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2906
FOSTER CARE SOCIAL SECURITY
BENEFITS. THE ACTION IS DUE.
PASS WRITTEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB FROM AB 1885.
THE BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB 2906 FOSTER
CARE. SOCIAL SECURITY BENEFITS
OKAY AB 3265 SEQUOIA MEDIA
CAMPUS PROJECTS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL.
VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. JONES. AYE. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE.
CIERTO. CIERTO I. WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE. 7 TO 0. 7 TO 0. THAT BILL
IS OUT. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER CALDERON. WE'LL START
WITH AB 2428 COMMUNITY-BASED
ADULT SERVICES. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR
TO ADD A COAUTHOR BÀN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2462 CðC WRITTEN REPORTS. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO ADD A
COAUTHOR. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2872. THE DEPARTMENT OF
INSURANCE SWORN MEMBERS.
COMPENSATION. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB
3030 HEALTH CARE, ARTIFICIAL
INTELLIGENCE. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR.
TO ADD A COAUTHOR BÀN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3193. STATE PROCUREMENT.
REHABILITATION SERVICES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED PER
THE AUTHOR, TO REVISE DGS
REPORTING REQUIREMENTS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3263 ELECTRICAL CORPORATIONS
FINANCING ORDERS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL.
VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. JONES. NO. ASHBY
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 1. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 1. MOVING ON
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER JUAN
CARRILLO. AB 2082. STATE ROUTE
138. RELINQUISHMENT THE ACTION
IS Dð. PASS ONE TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2109. ELECTRICITY.
INDUSTRIAL PROCESS. HEAT
RECOVERY. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2245 PERMANENT EMPLOYMENT STATUS.
ROSSI PE TEACHERS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2622 THE SUBJECT
IS CONTRACTORS EXEMPTION. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2736 VETERANS FEE WAIVER BENEFIT
PROGRAMS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2929 CHILD WELFARE SERVICES.
FAMILY FINDING. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. AB 3179 EMERGENCY
COMMUNICATION ZEVS. THE ACTION
IS Dð. PASS THE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON AN ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO WENDY CARRILLO. WE'LL
START WITH AB 1950. THE CHAVEZ
RAVINE DISPLACED RESIDENTS TASK
FORCE. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 2022. THAT BILL IS OUT
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2355
POLITICAL ADVERTISEMENTS.
ARTIFICIAL INTELLIGENCE. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2986 EAST LA AND UNINCORPORATED
AREAS. REPORT. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. I'M SORRY. COME BACK TO
ME. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY. AYE
BECKER. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD ALEJO'S. CIERTO.
NAVARRO. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE.
JOHNSTONE. JONES. NO 4 TO 1.
THAT BILL IS OUT. 4 TO 1. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER.
CERVANTES. AB 1807 RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. CITIZENS REDISTRICTING
COMMISSION. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE
BILL. BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5
TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
1899 JURY SELECTION DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO STRIKE SPECIFIED
PROVISIONS AND INSTEAD REQUIRE
JUDICIAL COUNCIL TO ADOPT A
STANDARD FOR JURORS TO EXPRESS
THEIR GENDER IDENTITY OR
EXPRESSION AS SPECIFIED, AND TO
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. NOT
VOTING. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0. AB 2279.
BUREAU OF MISSING AND MURDERED
INDIGENOUS WOMEN. GIRLS AND
PERSONS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
MAKE CLARIFYING AND TECHNICAL
CHANGES AND AMEND TO MAKE
PROVISIONS CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHEN. AB
2120 TRESSPASS. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. ASSEMBLY MEMBER
CONNELLY, WE'RE GOING TO START
WITH AB 99. CALTRANS INTEGRATED
PEST MANAGEMENT ON STATE
HIGHWAYS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
REVISE IMPLEMENTATION DATE TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 1860 FOR PESTICIDE
USE NEAR SCHOOL SITES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO ADD A
COAUTHOR. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2196
BEAVER RESTORATION. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES AND AMEND TO MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON APPROPRIATION.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2416 RESIDENTIAL
PROPERTY INSURANCE. WILDFIRE
RISK REGULATIONS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS IN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2734 CANNELLA
ENVIRONMENTAL FARMING ACT OF
1995. Dð PASS THAT WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2968. SCHOOL SAFETY AND FIRE
PREVENTION, COMMUNICATION AND
EVACUATION PLANS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REMOVE DEFENSIBLE
SPACE REQUIREMENTS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER DAVIS. AB
2308 DOMESTIC VIOLENCE
PROTECTIVE ORDERS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO ALLOW MODIFICATION OR
TERMINATION OF THE ORDER FOR
GOOD CAUSE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER DIXON. AB 2817.
STATE ROUTE ONE. RELINQUISHMENT.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER FLORA. AB
1254. STATE FIREFIGHTERS, THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AND AB
2534 CERTIFIED EMPLOYEES
EGREGIOUS MISCONDUCT. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR. TO ADD A COAUTHOR NGUYEN
A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL ON
THIS FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. ASSEMBLY MEMBER MIKE FONG. AB
2048 COMMUNITY COLLEGES TITLE
NINE WORKING GROUP DO PASS, AS
AMENDED PER AUTHOR, TO REPLACE
THE WORK GROUP WITH THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL OF 7 TO 0.
AB 2500 STUDENT FINANCIAL AID
APPLICATION DEADLINES. THE
ACTION IS Dð. PASS NGUYEN TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0 AS
WELL. AB 2931 COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PART TIME STUDENT TUTORS. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885 SO THAT THE BILL IS OUT
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
AB 3087 COMMUNITY COLLEGES
ECONOMIC AND WORKFORCE
DEVELOPMENT PROGRAM. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. NOW WE'RE MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER FRIEDMAN. FIRST
UP IS AB 810 POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION HIRING PRACTICES. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
1868 PROPERTY TAXATION
ASSESSMENTS OF AFFORDABLE
HOUSING. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL OF. 7 TO
0. AB 1889 GENERAL PLAN WILDLIFE
CONNECTIVITY ELEMENT. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REVISE CDF
CONSULTATION PROVISIONS AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 1963 PESTICIDE
PARAQUAT DICHLORIDE. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY
MADAM. CHAIR. YES. WILLING TO
VOTE AYE TODAY, BUT RESERVE THE
RIGHT TO CHANGE MY VOTE ON THE
FLOOR. ABSOLUTELY. THANK YOU.
ASHBY. AYE. BECKER AYE. BECKER.
AYE. BRADFORD CIERTO. CIERTO.
NO. WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 4240. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 4 TO 2. AB 2263.
CALIFORNIA. GUARANTEED INCOME
STUDY AND FUNDING ACT. THAT
ACTION IS DUE. PASS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2552 PESTICIDES.
ANTICOAGULANT RODENTICIDES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED,
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
EXEMPT CDFA AND REALLOCATE CIVIL
PENALTY REVENUE AS SPECIFIED.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY. I'M
SORRY. NUMBER 2552 A ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 1. THAT
BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 1. AB 2925.
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
ANTI-DISCRIMINATION TRAINING.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR. TO
CLARIFY THAT COLLEGES ARE NOT
PROHIBITED FROM OFFERING
ADDITIONAL TRAININGS TO OTHER
TARGETED GROUPS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GABRIEL.
AB 1053 MULTI-FAMILY HOUSING
PROGRAMS. EXPENDITURE OF LOAN
PROCEEDS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2316. PUPIL NUTRITION.
PROHIBITION ON SYNTHETIC FOOD
DYES. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL. VOTE. VOTE CABALLERO.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. JONES
ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. I.
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. CIERTO WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 5
TO 0. BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0. AB
2331. VOLUNTARY CARBON MARKET
DISCLOSURES. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED FOR THE AUTHOR
TO CLARIFY DISCLOSURE
REQUIREMENTS AND ALLOW
BUSINESSES TO COMPLY BY
REFERENCING MATERIAL AVAILABLE
ONLINE. NGUYEN. TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2455 WHISTLEBLOWER
PROTECTION STATE AND LOCAL
GOVERNMENT PROCEDURES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED, TO
STRIKE PROVISIONS RELATING TO
THE STATE PERSONNEL BOARD. BÀN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
18 EIGHT. AB 1885. SO THIS BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2621. LAW ENFORCEMENT
TRAINING. THE MOTION IS THE
ACTION IS DO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2899 HOSPITALS NURSE TO PATIENT
RATIOS. THE MOTION IS TO PASS.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. JONES. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. I. BECKER AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO
WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE. 6 TO 0. 6 TO
0. THAT BILL IS OUT. AB 3160.
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDIT
ALLOCATIONS. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED FOR THE AUTHOR
TO CLARIFY THE DATES OF
APPLICABILITY. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022, THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
THAT'S IT.
THANK YOU. BECAUSE WE'RE GOING
TO TAKE A LITTLE BREAK AND YEAH.
GOOD TIMING. FIVE MINUTES. YOU
WANT TO GO INTO RECESS
OFFICIALLY? YES. WE WILL RECESS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS FOR
FIVE MINUTES. GIVE EVERYBODY A
CHANCE TO STRETCH YOUR LEGS, DO
SOME CALISTHENICS, AND GET READY
FOR THE REST OF THE AGENDA.
CREATIONS WILL COME BACK TO
ORDER, AND WE WILL START WITH.
ASSEMBLY MEMBER GALLAGHER.
GRAYSON, DO WE KNOW GALLAGHER?
SORRY. YOU'RE RIGHT. WE'RE
STARTING WITH GALLAGHER. OKAY
FORWARDED. OKAY. WE'LL START
WITH AB 1938 EDUCATION SPECIAL
EDUCATION, LEAST RESTRICTIVE
ENVIRONMENT. ACTION IS DUE PASS.
WE WILL SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FOR AB 1885. BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2549. PATIENT VISITATION ACTION
IS DUE PASS. WE WILL SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM FROM AB 1885.
THIS BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB 2750
ELECTRICITY PROCUREMENT.
BIOMASS. THE ACTION IS TO PASS,
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
CLARIFY THE SCOPE NGUYEN TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER GARCIA. AB
1834 SUBJECT IS ELECTRICITY
SUPPLY STRATEGIC RELIABILITY
RESERVE PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS TO SUBSTITUTE A ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT OF A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. AB 1878 TRIBAL HOUSING
PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AGAIN. SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2098 HOSPITAL BRIDGE LOAN
PROGRAM ACTION Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, FOR THE AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES IN THE
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2757 SOUTHEAST CALIFORNIA
ECONOMIC REGION. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS AGAIN. THAT INFAMOUS
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2873 BREAKING BARRIERS
TO EMPLOYMENT INITIATIVE. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AND THIS IS A
ROLL CALL. VOTE CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. AYE.
JONES. AYE. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO
WAHAB. AYE. WAHAB. AYE. 6 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT. 6 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY. MEMBER GIBSON.
AB 2181. JUVENILE COURT. SCHOOL
PUPILS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2231. PAWNBROKERS. EDUCATION.
THE ACTION IS DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO SPECIFY FEES WILL
COVER ADMINISTRATIVE COSTS. THIS
IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. NO.
JONES. NÓ. ASHBY. AYE. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. I. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE CIERTO.
AYE. CIERTO. I WAHAB. WAHAB.
AYE. 6 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT. 6
TO 1. 6 TO 1. AB 2465. SOCIAL
SOCIALLY DISADVANTAGED GROUPS
AND ORGANIZATION GRANTS DO PASS
AS AMENDED TO CLARIFY GRANT
PREFERENCES APPLY TO THE EXTENT
CONSISTENT WITH STATE AND
FEDERAL LAW, AND ADD
SEVERABILITY CLAUSES. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2975 OCCUPATIONAL
SAFETY AND HEALTH STANDARDS
WORKPLACE VIOLENCE PREVENTION
PLAN Dð PASS AS AMEND, THE
ACTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO REQUIRE STANDARD STANDARDS.
BOARD TO AMEND THE STANDARDS BY
2027 AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. THIS IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. ASHBY HI. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. I. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHAB HI. WAHAB. AYE. 5 TO 0. 5
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT AB 2984,
FLEEING THE SCENE OF AN
ACCIDENT. STATUTE OF LIMITATION.
ACTION IS DUE. PASS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER GRAYSON.
WE'RE STARTING WITH AB 52 INCOME
TAX CREDIT SALES TAX PAID ON
MANUFACTURING EQUIPMENT. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885, THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 1296 BAR PILOTS.
REGULATION OF VESSELS. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO. THIS IS A ROLL CALL. VOTE
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. JONES. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
CIERTO. AYE. WAHAB. NO WAHAB.
NO. 6 TO 1. 6 TO 1. THAT BILL IS
OUT. 20 AB 2091. CEQA EXEMPTION
NON-MOTORIZED RECREATION. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO
MAKE PROVISIONS APPLICABLE TO
THE CONVERSION OF PREEXISTING
RAIL LINES AS SPECIFIED. THIS IS
A ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO.
AYE. CABALLERO. AYE. JONES.
ASHBY AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER. I
BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. CIERTO WAHAB. WAHAB. AYE 5
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO AB 29 2434. HEALTH
COVERAGE ENGINEERING INDUSTRY DO
PASS IS THE ACTION. THIS IS
THIS. WE'RE IN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL
OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO AB 2538
CAL FIRE SEASONAL FIREFIGHTERS.
THIS IS THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
NGUYEN TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. AB 2821. POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION. STUDENTS WITH
DISABILITIES SAID Dð PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. AB 3012 DEVELOPMENT FEES. FEE
ESTIMATE TOOL THIS IS A Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HANEY. AB 1976
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY AND HEALTH
STANDARDS. FIRST AID KITS.
NALOXONE HYDROCHLORIDE AND THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO DELAY
IMPLEMENTATION AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2115 CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES.
SUBSTANCES CLINICS. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED, FOR THE
AUTHOR TO ADD AN URGENCY CLAUSE
AND MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO. AYE.
JONES. JONES. AYE. ASHBY. ASHBY.
AYE. BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
WAHHAB A WAHHAB. AYE. 6 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT. 6 TO 0. AB
2182. PUBLIC WORKS. ACTION. Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES THAT WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2475 PAROLE. THE
ACTION IS DUE. PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE MOTION THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. AB 2629. FIREARMS PROHIBITED
PERSONS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED, TO STRIKE PROVISIONS
OF THE BILL RELATING TO
MISDEMEANORS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3061 AUTONOMOUS VEHICLE INCIDENT
REPORTING THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
DELETE TRAFFIC CITATION
REPORTING AND REVISE THE CONTENT
OF OTHER INFORMATION THAT MUST
BE REPORTED TO THE DMV. WE'LL
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 3190 PUBLIC WORKS.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO LIMIT THE BILL TO
LOW INCOME HOUSING TAX CREDITS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A 5 TO 2 VOTE, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. MOVING ON
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER HART. AB 1866
OIL AND GAS IDLE WELLS. THIS IS
A Dð PASS. ACTION. ROLL CALL
PLEASE. CABALLERO. AYE.
CABALLERO. AYE. JONES. NO.
JONES. NO. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
CIERTO. NO. CIERTO. NO. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE 44 TO 1. THIS BILL IS
OUT FOR 42. NØ SORRY. NO. 4 TO
2. THANK YOU. THAT BILL IS OUT.
4 TO 2. AB 2310. PAROLE HEARINGS.
LANGUAGE ACCESS DO PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR TO
INSTEAD REQUIRE BPH TO TRANSLATE
SPECIFIED FORMS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2407 PUBLIC POST-SECONDARY
INSTITUTION AUDITS OF SEXUAL
HARASSMENT COMPLAINTS. THIS IS A
DO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER HOLDEN. AB 359. COLLEGE
AND CAREER. ACCESS PATHWAYS. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885 AND THE BILL SO THAT THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 1826 DIGITAL
EQUITY IN VIDEO FRANCHISING ACT.
WE'RE GOING THE MOTION. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR TO RENAME THE ACT
AND MODIFY DEFINITIONS, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2022. THAT BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2193
HAZING EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
CLARIFY THAT THE BILL IS NOT
RETROACTIVE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2330 INCIDENTAL
TAKE WILDFIRE FIRE. WILDFIRE
PREPAREDNESS. THIS IS A Dð PASS
ACTION. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER HOOVER.
FIRST UP IS AB 2903 HOMELESSNESS
PROGRAM COSTS AND OUTCOME DATA.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO REQUIRE
COORDINATION ON DATA COLLECTION
AND REPORTING PROCEDURES AND TO
ADDRESS CHAPTERING ISSUES. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE 7 TO 0.
AB 3216. SCHOOL POLICIES ON
SMARTPHONES, PHONES. THE. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR. TO ADD
COAUTHORS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER ERWIN AB,
660. FOOD LABELING DATES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO EXEMPT BEER
AND MALT BEVERAGES AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL. CABALLERO A CABALLERO
I JONES NO. JONES NO. ASHBY I,
ASHBY I BECKER. BECKER I
BRADFORD BRADFORD I CIERTO WAHAB.
ALL RIGHT. WE HAVE A 5 TO 1.
THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO 1 AB 1575
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION STUDENT
ADVOCATES DO PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2426 CONSUMER PROTECTION DIGITAL
GOODS DO PASS, AS AMENDED, PER
THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE TECHNICAL
AND CLARIFYING CHANGES, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2854
BRADLEY BURNS UNIFORM, LOCAL
SALES AND USE TAX LAW. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MODIFY THE
PENALTY PROVISION. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO A,
CABALLERO I, JONES I, JONES I,
ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER I. BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I CIERTO
CIERTO NO WAHAB WAHHAB I 6 TO 1.
THE BILL IS OUT 6 TO 1 MOVING ON
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER JACKSON AB
637 ADVANCED CLEAN FLEETS RENTAL
VEHICLES. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
STRIKE THE APA EXEMPTION, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THIS BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. AB 1801 SUPPORTIVE HOUSING,
ADMINISTRATIVE OFFICE SPACE. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
1877 JUVENILE RECORD SEALING THE
MOTION. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED PER PER THE AUTHOR TO
CLARIFY DOJ'S RESPONSIBILITY.
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON
A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2448
ELECTRIC VEHICLE ECONOMIC
OPPORTUNITY ZONE, RIVERSIDE
COUNTY. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS.
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. CABALLERO
Ã CABALLERO I. JONES NØ JONES
NØ ASHBY. ASHBY I BECKER. BECKER
I BRADFORD. BRADFORD I. CIERTO I
SECRETO I WAHHAB I WAHHAB I 6 TO
1. THAT BILL IS OUT 6 TO 1 AB
2936. HIGHER EDUCATION
RECONCILIATION RECONCILIATION
MASTER PLAN. THE ACTION IS TO
PASS AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR,
TO MAKE THE COMMUNITY COLLEGES
PROVISION CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER JONES
SAWYER, STARTING WITH AB 1137.
SUBJECT IS EXCLUDED. EMPLOYEES,
THIS IS A Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 3089 CHATTEL
SLAVERY. FORMER FORMAL APOLOGY.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS. THIS IS
A ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO A
CABALLERO I JONES. ASHBY I ASHBY
I BECKER I BECKER I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CIERTO NÓ WAHAB I
WAHAB I 5 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT
5 TO 0 AB 31 008 MORTGAGE FRAUD.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3142 CALIFORNIA MOBILE CLIMATE
CHANGE EDUCATION. THE ACTION IS
Dð Dð PASS. PLEASE CALL THE
ROLL. CABALLERO, A, CABALLERO I
JONES. ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER.
BECKER I BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
CIERTO. WAHAB WAHAB I 5 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHOLERA.
FIRST UP IS AB 1082 AUTHORITY TO
REMOVE VEHICLES. ACTION Dð
PASSES AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR TO
DELETE THE DMV IMPACTS. DELETE
THE AUTHORITY FOR HIGHER ED
INSTITUTIONS TO CONDUCT FIVE
TICKET TOWS AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022, THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 1581
RESTORATION MANAGEMENT PERMITS
Dð PASSES AMENDED TO PROHIBIT
PERMIT ISSUANCE FOR SPECIFIED
PROJECT PROJECTS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885, THE BILL IS OUT OF A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2509 INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT.
INVASIVE SPECIES. DEFINITION.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
STRIKE THE DEFINITION OF
INTEGRATED PEST MANAGEMENT AND
REQUIRE THE COUNCIL TO
PRIORITIZE, PRIORITIZE, SPECIAL
SPECIFIED ACTIVITIES. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885, THE BILL IS OUT ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2602 PERSONAL OR PROFESSIONAL
SERVICE SERVICES. DIGITAL
DIGITAL REPLICAS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885, THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2926. PRESERVATION
NOTICE LAW NOTICE OF EXPIRATION
OF AFFORDABILITY RESTRICTIONS.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0, AND AB 3021 INTERROGATIONS.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAY BE 2022. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. WE'RE
GOING TO MOVE ON TO THE
COMMITTEE ON JUDICIARY, WHICH
ASSEMBLY MEMBER KALRA CHAIRS AND
FIRST UP IS AB 3280. LACTATION
ROOMS. JUDICIAL COUNCIL REPORT
ACTION IS DUE PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3282 COURTS SALE OF PROPERTY.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
STRIKE CIVIL FEE PROVISIONS AND
INSTEAD REQUIRE A REPORT TO THE
LEGISLATURE. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE,
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAY BE 1885,
THE BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0, MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LACKEY AB. 1973
INCOME AND CORPORATION TAX
EXCLUSIONS. BOBCAT FIRE. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0 AND AB
2645. ELECTRONIC TOLL COLLECTION
SYSTEMS. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
AGAIN, WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THAT
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS ROLL
CALL 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE AB 2346.
ORGANIC WASTE REDUCTION
PROCUREMENT PROJECT PROJECTS DO
PASS AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR,
TO NARROW THE SCOPE OF THE
PROGRAM CHANGES, WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, MOVING
ON TO AB 2454 DRINKING WATER
RENTAL PARK PROPERTY. THE ACTION
IS TO PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO STREAMLINE THE STATE
WATER BOARD WORKLOAD. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL. CABALLERO I,
CABALLERO I, JONES NO. JONES NO.
ASHBY. ASHBY I BECKER. BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I CIERTO
CIERTO. NO WAHAB. GREAT I WAHAB
I 5 TO 2 5 TO 2. THAT BILL IS
OUT MOVING ON TO AB 3031 LGBTQ
PLUS COMMISSION. THE ACTION IS
TO PASS AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
AND ADD A COAUTHOR AMEND TO
SPECIFY THAT THE COMMISSION IS
WITHIN OPR AND ALLOW IT TO
ACCEPT DONATIONS. THIS IS A ROLL
CALL VOTE. CABALLERO I,
CABALLERO I, JONES. NOT VOTING.
ASHBY I, ASHBY I BECKER I BECKER
I BRADFORD. BRADFORD I CIERTO
WAHAB I WAHAB I 5 TO 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT 5 TO 0 AB 3229
CALIFORNIA FRUIT AND VEGETABLE
ATE PILOT ACTION DO PASS AS
AMENDED FOR THE AUTHOR TO DELAY
THE REPORT. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. ASSEMBLY MEMBER LEE
IS THE CHAIR OF THE COMMITTEE ON
HUMAN SERVICES, AND THEIR BILL
IS AB 3291, WHICH IS
DEVELOPMENTAL SERVICES AND THIS
IS A ACTION IS DUE PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOW AB 884 ELECTIONS. LANGUAGE
ACCESSIBILITY. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR,
TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
1577 NURSING CLINICAL PLACEMENT
ACTION IS DUE PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE A ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2132 TUBERCULOSIS.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS, AS
AMENDED, FOR THE AUTHOR TO
REDUCE THE DUTIES OF THE
DEPARTMENT OF PUBLIC HEALTH.
THIS IS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885 SO THAT THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AB
2883 POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION
LUNAR NEW YEAR HOLIDAY. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS NGUYEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885 SO THAT THE BILL IS OUT
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
AB 2892 VEHICLES. FINANCIAL
RESPONSIBILITY. SELF INSURANCE.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AGAIN.
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THAT BILL IS OUT. THIS
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 3034 PUBLIC
POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION TUITION
WAIVERS FOR CALIFORNIA
CONSERVATION CORPS. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO ESTABLISH SPECIFIED
REQUIREMENTS FOR THE WAIVERS.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO AYE. CABALLERO AYE.
JONES NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY.
ASHBY. AYE BECKER. BECKER. AYE.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO.
CIERTO. NO WAHAB I WAHAB. AYE 5
TO 2. 5 TO 2. THAT BILL IS OUT.
NEXT UP IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER
LOWENTHAL AB 2389. ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES DRINK SPIKING
REPORTING. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED TO NARROW THE SCOPE
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3172 SOCIAL MEDIA PLATFORMS.
INJURIES TO CHILDREN. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED, TO
SPECIFY THAT THE SOCIAL MEDIA
PLATFORM MUST KNOWINGLY OR
WILLFULLY BREACH ITS
RESPONSIBILITY, ESTABLISH THE
SAFE SOCIAL MEDIA FUND, AND
REQUIRE THE CIVIL PENALTIES TO
BE DEPOSITED INTO THAT FUND.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL. CABALLERO
AYE. CABALLERO AYE. JONES. NO.
JONES. NO. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO. WAHAB
WAHAB. AYE 5 TO 1. THAT BILL IS
OUT. 5 TO 1. NEXT UP IS ASSEMBLY
MEMBER MANCINI. AB 2063 HEALTH
COVERAGE. PILOT. PILOT BRADFORD.
RISK BEARING ARRANGEMENTS. UNTIL
WE FIND OUT HE LEAVES. I THINK
WE CAN GO FORWARD. AND THEN IF
WE FIND OUT HE'S LEFT, THEN WE
NEED. TO. I'M GOING TO TAKE A
MINI BREAK RIGHT NOW.
AND WE CAN REESTABLISH. IT'S A
LITTLE MORE WORDY BECAUSE YOU
GOT TO SAY HE'S NOT VOTING ON
SUNDAYS, BUT THAT'S FINE. DO WE
NEED TO READ THROUGH THIS? THIS
THE SENATE APPROPRIATIONS
COMMITTEE WILL BE BACK IN
SESSION, AND WE'RE READY TO TAKE
UP THE BILLS FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MANCINI. WE'LL START WITH AB
2063 HEALTH COVERAGE PILOT RISK
BEARING ARRANGEMENTS. THIS IS A
Dð PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL.
CABALLERO Ã CABALLERO I JONES
JONES I ASHBY. ASHBY I BECKER I
BECKER I BRADFORD. CIERTO CIERTO
I WAHAB WAHHAB I. BILL IS OUT 6
TO 0 WITH BRADFORD ABSENT MOVE.
I ASK ONE QUICK QUESTION BEFORE
WE MOVE.
THANK YOU. MOVING ON TO AB 2739
FIREARMS DO PASS AS AMENDED TO
STRIKE PROVISIONS RELATED TO
DIVERSION. PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
CABALLERO Ã. CABALLERO I. JONES
NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY. ASHBY AYE.
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
CIERTO. NO. CIERTO NO. WAHAB.
WAHAB. AYE 32. THE BILL IS OUT
42. MOVING ON TO AB 2087. SCHOOL
MEDICAL EMERGENCY PROCEDURES.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO INCORPORATE
REQUIREMENTS INTO SCHOOL SAFETY
PLAN UPDATES. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE,
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2063, THAT
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0,
WITH BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB 2971
CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE STAFFING
RATIO WORKGROUP COMMUNITY
COLLEGE DISTRICTS. THE ACTION IS
DUE PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2739, THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH
RIVAS VOTING NO AND BRADFORD NOT
VOTING AB 3064. FIREARM SAFETY
DEVICES DO PASS, AS AMENDED, PER
THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE 2739, THAT
VOTE THAT BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 4 TO 2, WITH RIVAS VOTING
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
BRADFORD NOT VOTING. I'M GOING
TO MOVE ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MATHIS. AB 2423 DEVELOPMENTAL
SERVICE RATES. THE ACTION IS TO
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 20 2063. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MCCARTY. AB 2088 K14 CLASSIFIED
EMPLOYEE VACANCIES. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE. CABALLERO A CABALLERO I
JONES. NO. JONES NO. ASHBY NO.
ASHBY. NO. BECKER. BECKER I
BRADFORD. CIERTO. NO. CIERTO. NO
WAHAB. WAHAB I PASSED 3 TO 3.
WHY WOULD WE DO ABOUT ASHBY NOW?
I JUST PUT IT ON CALL. YEAH.
WE'RE GOING TO PUT THIS ONE ON
CALL. MOVING ON TO AB 2106
PROBATION DO PASS AS AMENDED PER
THE AUTHOR, TO ESTABLISH A
SLIDING SCALE BASED ON INCOME
FOR DEFENDANTS TO PAY FOR THE
TREATMENT PROGRAM. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2063, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH BRADFORD
NOT VOTING. MOVING ON TO AB 2427
ELECTRIC VEHICLE CHARGING
STATIONS. CURBSIDE CHARGING
PERMITTING. THIS IS A Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO DELETE
REQUIREMENTS TO IDENTIFY
LOCATIONS FOR EV CHARGING
STATIONS IN PUBLIC RIGHTS OF
WAY. THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO, A, CABALLERO I JONES
VOTING. ASHBY I ASHBY I BECKER
BECKER I BRADFORD CIERTO NH█P
WAHAB I WAHAB. AYE 4 TO 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT 4 TO 0 AB 2508
CALIFORNIA KIDS INVESTMENT AND
DEVELOPMENT SAVINGS PROGRAM. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2063. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 6 TO 0, WITH BRADFORD NOT NOT
VOTING, MOVING ON TO 2565.
SCHOOL FACILITIES. INTERIOR
LOCKS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO ADD
FINDINGS AND DECLARATIONS AND TO
AMEND TO MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2063, THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0,
WITH BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
3131. THE CTE INCENTIVE GRANT
AND STRONG WORKFORCE PROGRAMS.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR TO ADD
COAUTHORS WAYS BACK. THAT IS
OKAY. WE'RE GONNA SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. WE'RE GOING TO GO BACK TO
MCCARTY AB 2088, WHICH IS THE K
14 CLASSIFIED EMPLOYEE VACANCIES
WILL OPEN THE ROLL CALL. ONE
MORE TIME. BRADFORD ALL RIGHT.
BRADFORD I THE VOTE IS 4 TO 3.
THAT BILL IS OUT 4 TO 3. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER SKINNER AB
1997 TEACHERS RETIREMENT LAW.
THAT IS A ACTION IS TO PASS WHEN
A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2335. PUBLIC EMPLOYMENT
COMPENSATION AND CLASSIFICATION.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE A ROLL CALL
FOR MAY BE 2022. THE BILL IS OUT
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2561
LOCAL PUBLIC EMPLOYEES VACANT
POSITIONS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
RAISE THE VACANCY THRESHOLD,
ELIMINATE THE MONITORING
REQUIREMENT, AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2780, THE CARRIER
CARRIER OF PASSENGERS ACT OF
2024 ACTION IS DUE PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR MAY
BE 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. MURATSUCHI AB 1917
SCHOOL DISTRICT BOARD MEMBERS.
GOVERNANCE TRAINING. THE ACTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO SPECIFY HOW ENTITIES
CAN SATISFY THE CONSULTATION
REQUIREMENT. THIS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2074 ENGLISH LEARNER ROADMAP.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED, TO REMOVE THE
REQUIREMENT TO ESTABLISH
POSITIONS AND A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAY BE 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2134 SCHOOL
EMPLOYEES. TRANSFER OF SICK
LEAVE. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AND
FINALLY. COMMITTEE ON EDUCATION,
CHAIRED BY ASSEMBLY MEMBER
MURATSUCHI AB 2473 TEACHER
CREDENTIALING AUTHORIZATIONS.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
TECHNICAL CHANGES AND ADDRESS
CHAPTER ISSUES WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885, THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, MOVING
ON TO STEPHANIE NGUYEN. FIRST
STEP IS AB 1808 CALWORKS CHILD
CARE. IT'S A Dð PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. BILL IS OUT
ON UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
30 2317. CHILD CARE. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2992 REAL ESTATE LAW BUYER
BROKER AGREEMENTS. THE ACTIONS
DO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAY BE 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0, AND FINALLY AB 3042
NHÀ FUND. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS,
AS AMENDED, TO EXTEND THE SUNSET
TO JANUARY 1ST, 2028. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. KIMBERLY, DO YOU WANT TO GO
THROUGH UNTIL SHE COMES BACK?
WE'RE GOING TO TAKE UP ASSEMBLY
MEMBER ORTEGA AB 2068 CALL
CENTERS REPORTING THE ACTION IS
DUE PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE A ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2 WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. NEXT UP IS AB 2271
SAINT ROSE HOSPITAL. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2446 MEDI-CAL DIAPERS. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASSES AMENDED TO
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION. WE'RE IN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND AB
2959 PRISON VENDING MACHINES.
WE'RE GOING THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR,
TO STRIKE SPECIFIED PROVISIONS.
AMEND TO ENSURE THAT VENDING
ITEMS DO NOT EXCEED SPECIFIED
MARKUPS. SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2022. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AND LET
ME KNOW. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER PACHECO AB 2024 DOMESTIC
VIOLENCE RESTRAINING ORDER. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3241 POLICE CANINES. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED TO STRIKE
REQUIREMENT TO DEVELOP STANDARDS
AND INSTEAD REQUIRE POST TO
ISSUE RECOMMENDATIONS TO THE
LEGISLATURE. THAT IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE. CABALLERO A, CABALLERO I,
JONES JONES I, ASHBY I ASHBY I
BECKER I BECKER I BRADFORD
BRADFORD I CIERTO CIERTO I WAHIB
WAHAB I 7 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT
7 TO 0. ASSEMBLY MEMBER PAPIN
STARTING WITH AB 2515 MENSTRUAL
PROJECTS FAS THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO REQUIRE THE
DTSC DETERMINE FAS THRESHOLDS.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO I JONES NOT VOTING
ASHBY I ASHBY I BECKER. BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I CIERTO
WAHAB. HI WAHAB I 5 TO 0. YES 5
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT AB 2842
FIREARMS DO PASS AS AMENDED PER
THE AUTHOR TO ADD COAUTHORS AND
MAKE A TECHNICAL CHANGE WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3023 WATERSHED RESTORATION AND
FOREST RESILIENCE PLAN.
RESILIENCE PLANS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REQUIRE AN
INTERAGENCY FUNDING STRATEGY.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY. ASSEMBLYMEMBER JIM
PATTERSON, AB 2471, PUBLIC
HEALTH NURSES. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR,
TO MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES. THIS
IS A ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO
Ã, CABALLERO I, JONES I, JONES
I, ASHBY I, ASHBY I BECKER I.
BECKER I BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
CIERTO CIERTO I WAHAB WAHHAB I 7
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT 7 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO JOE PATTERSON.
FIRST UP IS AB 2589 ALCOHOLIC
BEVERAGES LICENSES. THE ACTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR. TO NARROW THE SCOPE
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THAT
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 3156 MEDI-CAL
MANAGED CARE PLANS MOTION. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3245 CORRECT. CANCER SCREENING.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER PELLERIN
AB 1111 CANNABIS SMALL PRODUCER
EVENT SALES LICENSE. THE ACTION
IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO DELAY IMPLEMENTATION
AND REVISE LICENSE REQUIREMENTS.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO Ã, CABALLERO I, JONES.
ASHBY I, ASHBY I, BECKER I.
BECKER I BRADFORD VÚI CIERTO
WAHHAB I WAHAB. AYE. 4 TO 0.
BILL IS OUT 4 TO 0 AB 1907 CHILD
WELFARE DATA DO PASS AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR. CONTINGENT UPON
APPROPRIATION TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. MOVING ON TO AB 2103 BIG
BASIN REDWOODS, ANO NUEVO AND
BUTANO STATE PARK DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CHANGES TO THE PUBLIC HEARING
PROCESS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE, CABALLERO I, CABALLERO I,
JONES NO. JONES NO. ASHBY I
ASHBY I BECKER I BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I CIERTO.
WAHAB I WAHAB I 5 TO 1. THE BILL
IS OUT 5 TO 1 AB 2387 MOBILE
HOME PARKS ADDITIONAL LOTS. THE
Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 1885. THAT BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2496 FOSTER FAMILY AGENCIES DO
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAY BE 1885. SO THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2839. ELECTIONS.
DECEPTIVE MEDIA ADVERTISEMENTS
DO PASS, AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR. TO NARROW THE SCOPE,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAY BE 2022. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
AB 2866 CHILD CARE POOL SAFETY.
THE ACTION IS TO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
PETRIE-NORRIS. FIRST UP IS AB 20
042004. COUNTY RECORD REPORT.
COUNTY RECORDER DOCUMENTS ACTION
IS DUE. PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2096 RESTRAINING ORDERS.
EDUCATIONAL INSTITUTIONS DO PASS
THIS. MORGAN, SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. AB 2368. ELECTRICITY
RELIABILITY Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2490. REPRODUCTIVE HEALTH
EMERGENCY PREPAREDNESS PROGRAM.
THE ACTION IS TO PASS AS
AMENDED, FOR THE AUTHOR TO ALLOW
PRIVATE SOURCES OF FUNDING WHEN
A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2672 CARE PROGRAM
HOME Kò FACILITIES. THE ACTION
IS DUE PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE 1885.
THE BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER QUIRK-SILVA AB
1788 MENTAL HEALTH
MULTIDISCIPLINARY PERSONNEL
TEAMS ACTION IS Dð PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
TECHNICAL AND CLARIFYING
CHANGES. OOPS, SORRY. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. AB 2038 STATE PARKS OUTDOOR
EQUITY PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885, AND
THE BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AB 2137 HOMELESS
AND FOSTER YOUTH. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE. THAT SAID, DO PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885 AND THE
BILL IS OUT ON UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. AB 2395 CSU CONTINUING
EDUCATION PROGRAM REVENUES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2555 SALES AND USE
TAX EXEMPTION. DONATIONS OF
MEDICINAL CANNABIS. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885 AND THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS AB
1284 TRIBAL CO-GOVERNANCE AND
CO-MANAGEMENT AGREEMENTS. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885, THAT BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2108. FOSTER CARE. MISSING
CHILDREN. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. A BILL IS OUT
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
AB 2138. PEACE OFFICER TRIBAL
POLICE PILOT PROGRAM. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885, AND THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2695 LAW ENFORCEMENT TRIBAL
AFFILIATION. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THAT
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AND FINALLY AB 2711
PUPILS SUSPENSION CONTROLLED
SUBSTANCE DISCLOSURE. THE ACTION
IS Dð. PASS WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2022. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RENDON, AB 2202 SHORT
TERM RENTALS CLEANING
DISCLOSURES. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR,
TO INCLUDE ADVERTISEMENTS FOR
SHORT TERM LODGING. AMEND TO
CLARIFY, THE BILL APPLIES TO
ADVERTISEMENTS IN THE STATE.
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL
FOR MAY BE 2022, THE BILL IS OUT
ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2373
MOBILE HOME TENANCIES ACTION IS
DUE PASS. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885 AND THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2696 LABOR RELATED
LIABILITIES. DIRECT CONTRACTOR
AND SUBCONTRACTOR. THE ACTION IS
TO PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
2022. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2750 FOR
EMPLOYMENT CONTRACTS AND
AGREEMENTS LIABILITY. THE Dð
PASS ACTION WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022, THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. 2834
PUBLIC POST-SECONDARY EDUCATION.
PART TIME FACULTY. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885, A BILL
IS OUT ON UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO
0. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
REYES, WE'LL START WITH AB 653
FEDERAL HOUSING VOUCHER
ACCELERATION PROGRAM. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO STRIKE THE GRANT
PROGRAM AND DELAY THE DEADLINE
FOR THE INITIAL REPORTS. THIS IS
A ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO, A
CABALLERO I JONES NOT VOTING.
ASHBY NO. ASHBY. NO. BECKER I.
BECKER I. BRADFORD. BRADFORD I
CIERTO. WAHAB WAHAB. AYE. 4 TO
1. THAT BILLS OUT 4 TO 1 AB
2033. PUBLIC POST-SECONDARY
EDUCATION BASIC NEEDS FOR
STUDENTS. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT WITH A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. AB 2165 STUDENT
FINANCIAL AID EXEMPTIONS. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
FOR THE AUTHOR TO REMOVE DATA
COLLECTION. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885 THAT THE BILL IS OUT WITH A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. NEXT
UP IS AB 2207 STATE BOARDS AND
COMMISSION OLDER ADULTS. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO REVISE
IMPACTS TO STATE ENTITIES. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885. SO THE BILL
IS OUT WITH A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. AB 2440 30. BY 30 GOAL.
THE ACTION IS TO PASS, AS
AMENDED, FOR THE AUTHOR TO MAKE
REQUIREMENTS FEASIBLE. Ã HØI
JONES I, JONES I, ASHBY I, ASHBY
I. BECKER. BECKER I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. I CIERTO WAHAB I WAHAB
I 6 TO 0 AB 2724 HIGH SCHOOL 6
TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT I'M SORRY
MAYBE 2720 FOR HIGH SCHOOL
PUPILS VOTER REGISTRATION. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED
PER THE AUTHOR TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR MAY
BE 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER THREE OF US AB 799 CAL H
FUNDING. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED, FOR THE AUTHOR TO
DELAY DATA REPORTING AND
PUBLISHING DEADLINES AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT WITH
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2364 PROPERTY SERVICE WORKER
PROTECTION ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED, FOR THE AUTHOR TO
CONVERT TO A STUDY BILL. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2022. THAT BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AND AB
2738 ALTERNATIVE ENFORCEMENT
OCCUPATIONAL SAFETY DO PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAY BE 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON
A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. MOVING ON
TO THE SPEAKER, RIVAS AB 2830
FOSTER CARE RELATIVE CAREGIVERS.
THE ACTION IS TO PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 1885, AND THE BILL
IS OUT WITH WITH A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RODRIGUEZ, AB
977. EMERGENCY DEPARTMENTS.
ASSAULT AND BATTERY. THE ACTION
IS TO PASS A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS ROLL CALL.
RODRIGUEZ AB 1792 EMERGENCY
MEDICAL SERVICES. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS AGAIN. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
2348. EMERGENCY MEDICAL
SERVICES, THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. SO THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0. AB 2983 CALIFORNIA
WILDFIRE MITIGATION PROGRAM
INSURANCE AVAILABILITY. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AND
THE COMMITTEE ON EMERGENCY
MANAGEMENT, WHICH ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RODRIGUEZ CHAIRS AB 2469,
EMERGENCY MANAGEMENT ASSISTANT
ASSISTANCE COMPACT, AND
CALIFORNIA WILDFIRE MITIGATION
PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885. SO THE BILL IS OUT
ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0.
MOVING ON TO BLANCA RUBIO AB
1839 LABOR TRAFFICKING TASK
FORCE. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS, AS
AMENDED, TO CLARIFY
RESPONSIBILITIES OF THE CRD.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FOR AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0 WITH AB 1832. THAT WAS
1832. MY APOLOGIES IF I
MISSPOKE. THE NEXT IS AB 2725
TEACHER CREDENTIALING,
OCCUPATIONAL AND PHYSICAL
THERAPIST. IT'S A Dð PASS MOTION
OR ACTION, AND WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER SANCHEZ.
AB 1874 SECRETLY RECORDING A
MINOR. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0, MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER SANTIAGO AB 1511. ETHNIC
AND COMMUNITY MEDIA PROGRAM. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS ON A ROLL CALL
VOTE. CABALLERO I, CABALLERO I,
JONES. ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER.
BECKER I BRADFORD. BRADFORD. I
CIERTO. WAHAB. WAHHAB I 5 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT 5 TO 0. AB 29
I'M SORRY 2093 COMMUNITY COLLEGE
FEE WAIVERS. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED FOR THE AUTHOR
TO MAKE THE FEE WAIVERS
PERMISSIVE. THIS IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE CABALLERO A CABALLERO I
JONES A, JONES I. ASHBY I ASHBY
I BECKER. BECKER I BRADFORD.
BRADFORD I CIERTO WAHAB I WAHAB
I 6 TO 0. THAT BILL IS OUT 6 TO
0. AB 2667. AFFIRMATIVELY
FURTHERING FAIR HOUSING
REPORTING Dð PASS IS THE ACTION
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAY BE 2022. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB
2910 CONVERSION OF COMMERCIAL
BUILDINGS. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR,
TO DELETE BUILDING STANDARDS
COMMISSION CONSULTATION
REQUIREMENT AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THAT BILL IS OUT ON
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. MOVING
ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER SCHIAVO.
AB 2086 CALIFORNIA
TRANSPORTATION PLAN AND PUBLIC
DASHBOARD. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS,, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REQUIRE THE FINANCIAL
ELEMENT TO SUMMARIZE AND LIMIT
THE DATA POSTING REQUIREMENT TO
SPECIFIED PROGRAMS. THIS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAY BE 1885. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7
TO 0. AB 2499 UNLAWFUL
EMPLOYMENT PRACTICES
DISCRIMINATION FOR TIME OFF DUE
PASSES AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR,
TO MAKE CLARIFYING CHANGES
REGARDING FORMS. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2022, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF FIVE 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB 2670
AWARENESS CAMPAIGN. ABORTION
SERVICES DO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM 20
2022. THAT BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 5 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AB 2999 PUPIL PUPIL
INSTRUCTION, HOMEWORK POLICY.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED, TO MAKE PERMISSIVE.
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885, THE BILL IS OUT ON
A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB
3074 SCHOOL ATHLETIC TEAM NAMES
AND MASCOTS. THE ACTION IS TO
CALL. THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
THE MOTION IS DUE. PASS.
CABALLERO A CABALLERO I JONES A
JONES I. ASHBY I ASHBY I BECKER
I. BECKER I BRADFORD BRADFORD I
CIERTO WAHAB WAHHAB I 6 TO 0.
THAT BILL IS OUT 6 TO 0. AND
FINALLY THE COMMITTEE ON
MILITARY AND VETERANS AFFAIRS
WHICH ASSEMBLY MEMBER CHAIRS THE
DEPARTMENT OF VETERANS AFFAIRS.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS. Þ. THIS
IS A ROLL CALL. VOTE SORRY.
CABALLERO. I CABALLERO I JONES.
ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER I BECKER I
BRADFORD. BRADFORD I CIERTO
WAHAB. HI WAHAB I 5 TO 0. THAT
BILL IS OUT. MOVING ON NOW TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER SORIA. FIRST UP
IS AB 2060 LSA EXEMPTIONS. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASSES AMENDED TO
REQUIRE BIOLOGICAL SURVEYS. CDPH
CONSULTATION AND IMPLEMENTATION
OF SPECIFIED MEASURE NGUYEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THIS BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. AB 20
104 BACCALAUREATE DEGREE IN
NURSING PILOT PROGRAM. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AND AB
3275 HEALTH PLANS CLAIM
REIMBURSEMENT. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. DO
PASS. I'M SORRY THAT HEALTH
PLANS CLAIM REIMBURSEMENT WAS
DUE PASS IN ITS 7 TO 0. OKAY.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER TO
AB 3045 ASIAN ZODIAC HEIRLOOM
BIRTH CERTIFICATES. THE ACTION
IS DUE PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 1885. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A UNANIMOUS VOTE
OF 7 TO 0, MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY
MEMBER TING AB. 347 PFAS TESTING
AND ENFORCEMENT. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO ADJUST TIMELINES AND
REMOVE ENFORCEMENT OF COSMETICS
AND COOKWARE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
FROM AB 2022 THAT THIS BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB
1780 PRIVATE POST-SECONDARY
INSTITUTIONS. LEGACY.
ADMISSIONS. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS, AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES TO THE REPORTING
REQUIREMENTS. WHEN A SUBSTITUTE,
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022. THIS
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
AB 2178 PRISON BED THRESHOLDS.
WE'RE GOING TO THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED TO MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES TO THE
REPORTING REQUIREMENT. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2022. SO THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AB
2401 CLEAN CARS FOR ALL THE
ACTION IS DUE. PASS WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THAT THAT. SO THE BILL
IS OUT WITH A UNANIMOUS VOTE OF
7 TO 0. AND THEN AB 2483
POST-CONVICTION PROCEEDINGS. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO AUTHORIZE
CDCR TO REDACT SPECIFIED RECORDS
AND MAKE OTHER TECHNICAL
CHANGES. THIS IS A ROLL CALL
VOTE. CABALLERO. AYE. CABALLERO.
AYE. JONES. WHAT NUMBER IS IT?
2024? 83? 83. NO JONES. NO.
ASHBY AYE. ASHBY. AYE. BECKER
AYE. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD.
BRADFORD. AYE. CIERTO. WAHAB IN
WHICH FILM? 20 2483 HÌNH. WAHAB
AYE. 5 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT. 5
TO 1. MOVING ON TO AB 2669. TOLL
BRIDGES AND TOLLS. THE ACTION IS
Dð PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2022, THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 5 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. ONE MORE
AND THEN WE'LL TAKE A BREAK.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLYMEMBER
VALENCIA. AB 2131 CERTIFIED
NURSE, NURSE, ASSISTANT TRAINING
PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS
AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR, TO
FURTHER SPECIFY REQUIREMENTS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 1885 OUT ON A UNANIMOUS
VOTE OF 7 TO 0, AB 2447 CSU
EXPENDITURES. INTERNET WEBSITES.
THE ACTION IS DUE. PASSES
AMENDED TO CHANGE THE
EXPENDITURE THRESHOLD TO $25,000
AND SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0, MOVING
ON TO WALDRON AB 2740
INCARCERATED PERSONS PRENATAL
AND POSTPARTUM CARE. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED, TO ALLOW
INCARCERATED MOTHERS TO REMAIN
AT THE HOSPITAL FOR AS LONG AS
THE MEDICAL PROVIDER DEEMS
NECESSARY, AND MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES REGARDING FAMILY. FAMILY
VISITATION ELIGIBILITY AND A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 1885. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
UNANIMOUS VOTE OF 7 TO 0. OKAY
TO THE PRIVATE, PRIVATELY. OR WE
CAN. WE'RE GOING TO TAKE ANOTHER
VERY QUICK RECESS OF FIVE
MINUTES, AND THEN WE'LL BE BACK.
AND I THINK WE SHOULD BE ABLE TO
FINISH UP.
THE APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE
WILL CONTINUE. WE'RE STILL IN
OUR SUSPENSE FILE. AND NEXT UP
IS ASSEMBLY MEMBER WALLACE. AB
2247 MOBILE HOME PARK
MAINTENANCE INSPECTION PROGRAM.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS. SO WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE 2063. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING,
MOVING ON TO AB 2277 COMMUNITY
COLLEGES, PART TIME FACULTY. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASSES AMENDED PER
THE AUTHOR, TO MAKE CLARIFYING
CHANGES. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 2063. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH SENATOR
BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB 2678
VEHICLES HOV LANES. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL.
KABI KABI CABALLERO YES, I
CABALLERO I YOU'RE ALL CONFUSED.
NO. JONES NO. ASHBY. ASHBY. AYE
BECKER. BECKER. AYE. BRADFORD
CIERTO. CIERTO I WAHAB I WAHAB.
AYE I HAVE 5 TO 1. THE BILL IS
OUT 5 TO 1. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WARD AB 1635 DMV
HILLCREST PROPERTY LEASING
AFFORDABLE HOUSING. THE ACTION
IS TO PASS WITH A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2739. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2 WITH
THE. THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
AND SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING.
MOVING ON TO AB 1858
COMPREHENSIVE SCHOOL SAFETY
PLANS. ACTIVE SHOOTERS. THE
ACTIONS DO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2063, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH SENATOR
BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB. 1884
PUPIL PUPIL EXCUSED ABSENCES FOR
SERVICE. DEPLOYMENTS. THE ACTION
IS TO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2063. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
1979 DOXXING VICTIMS RECOURSE
ACT. THE ACT, THE ACTION IS TO
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2739. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
AND SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING
AB 20 ZERO FIVE. CSU FACULTY AND
EMPLOYEE HOUSING. THE ACTION IS
DUE. PASS. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2739. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 4 TO 2, WITH THE REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO AND SENATOR BRADFORD
NOT VOTING AB 2353. PROPERTY
TAX, WELFARE EXEMPTION, INTEREST
AND PENALTIES ON DELINQUENT
PAYMENTS. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 2063, THE BILL IS OUT ON
A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH SENATOR
BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB 3093.
HOUSING ELEMENT AND RINA ACUTELY
LOW INCOME AND EXTREMELY LOW
INCOME HOUSEHOLDS, THE ACTIONS
DO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2739, THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH
THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING.
MOVING ON TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER
WEBER AB 1841 STUDENT SAFETY.
OPIOID OVERDOSE REVERSAL
MEDICATION. THE ACTION IS TO
PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2063, THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
1891 COMMUNITY COLLEGE ALLIED
HEALTH PROGRAMS. THE ACTION IS
TO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2063. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB.
1895 MATERNITY WARD CLOSE
CLOSURES. THE ACTION IS Dð PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2739. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB.
1919 PUPIL DISCIPLINE.
RESTORATIVE JUSTICE PRACTICES.
THE ACTIONS DO PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 2739. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING
COULD BE 1984 DATA ON STUDENT
TRANSFERS FROM ALTERNATIVE
COUNTY COMMUNITY AND
CONTINUATION SCHOOLS. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS, AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO NARROW THE SCOPE AND
DELAY IMPLEMENTATION WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2063, THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 6 TO 0, WITH SENATOR BRADFORD
NOT VOTING AB 2072. HEALTH
COVERAGE. BIOMEDICAL INDUSTRY.
THE ACTION IS Dð PASS BÀN A
SUBSTITUTE. THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2063. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH SENATOR
BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB 2119
MENTAL HEALTH. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS NGUYEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2063. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
2250. SOCIAL DETERMINANTS OF
HEALTH. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
AS AMENDED, FOR THE AUTHOR TO
MAKE CONTINGENT UPON AN
APPROPRIATION. WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE, THE ROLL CALL FOR
MAYBE 2739, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
3059 DONOR HUMAN MILK. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASS AND THIS IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO A
CABALLERO I JONES. JONES. NO.
ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER I. BECKER I
BRADFORD. CIERTO. WAHAB I WAHAB
I 4 TO 1. 4 TO 1. THAT BILL IS
OUT AB 3139. REMOTE VEHICLE
TECHNOLOGY. THE ACTION IS TO
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM 2063. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0
WITH SENATOR BRADFORD NOT
VOTING. I'M GOING TO MOVE ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WICKS. FIRST
STEP IS AB 886 CALIFORNIA
JOURNALISM PRESERVATION ACT.
THIS IS A DUE PASS ACTION WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2739 THAT THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO AND SENATOR BRADFORD
NOT VOTING AB 922 PREPARED MEALS
DELIVERY PROGRAM. THE ACTION IS
TO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2739. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH
THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO. A
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
1252 OFFICE OF GUN VIOLENCE
PREVENTION. THE ACTION IS Dð
PASS. WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2739. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2,
WITH THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO.
AND SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING.
THIS ONE WAS SUPPOSED TO GO TO
ROLL. IT'S SUPPOSED. TO.
MOVING ON TO AB 1893 HOUSING
ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. WE HAVE TO
DO FOR CONSIDERATION. THE ACTION
IS Dð PASS. THIS IS A ROLL CALL.
VOTE 23. WAIT 1893 ACCOUNT
HOUSING ACCOUNTABILITY ACT. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS WITH A ROLL
CALL. OKAY CDVA CABALLERO I,
CABALLERO I JONES I JONES I
ASHBY. ASHBY I BECKER I. BECKER
I BRADFORD CIERTO CIERTO I
WAHAB. NO. WAHAB NO. 5 TO 1. 5
TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT. MOVING
ON TO AB 1949 CALIFORNIA
CONSUMER PRIVACY ACT OF 2020
MINORS ACTION IS DUE PASS. AND
AGAIN THIS IS A ROLL CALL.
CABALLERO A CABALLERO I JONES.
NO. JONES. NO. ASHBY I ASHBY I
BECKER I. BECKER I BRADFORD
CIERTO. WAHAB A WAHAB I SORRY I
WAS CONFUSED TWO 4 TO 1. 4 TO 1.
4 TO 1. THAT BILL IS OUT. THROW
US A CURVEBALL OVER HERE. HE WAS
GETTING ALL EXCITED. YEAH. THEN
WE CAN KILL SOMETHING. MOVING ON
TO AB 1961. END HUNGER IN
CALIFORNIA ACT. THE ACTION IS
DUE. PASS AS AMENDED, PER THE
AUTHOR, TO MAKE CHANGES TO THE
TASK FORCE AND AMEND TO REMOVE
THE STRATEGIC GROWTH COUNCIL.
THIS IS WE'RE IN A SUBSTITUTE
THE ROLL CALL FROM AB 2063. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0,
WITH SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING.
SO WE HAVE TO RECONSIDER THE
VOTE ON THIS. OKAY.
MEMBERS. MY APOLOGY. WE HAVE ONE
BILL THAT WE NEED TO REDO AND
THAT IS AB 886. THE CALIFORNIA
JOURNALISM PRESERVATION ACT. I
INADVERTENTLY FORGOT TO LEAVE
OUT THAT WE IT'S A Dð PASS, BUT
IT'S A Dð PASS TO SEND A RULES.
SO IF WE COULD GRANT
RECONSIDERATION, IS THERE A
MOTION? SO MOVED. THERE IS A
MOTION. ANY OBJECTION? NO. WELL,
WITHOUT OBJECTION WE WILL DO
THIS AGAIN. AGAIN IT'S THE
CALIFORNIA JOURNALISM
PRESERVATION ACT AB 886 AND THE
ACTION IS DUE. PASS AND TO SEND
THE RULES, THIS IS WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2739. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 4 TO 2 WITH THE
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PATIENCE ON THAT ONE, WE'RE
STILL ON WICKS. WE'RE MOVING ON
TO AB 2243 AFFORDABLE HOUSING
AND HIGH ROADS JOBS ACT OF 2022.
THIS IS A ROLL CALL VOTE.
CABALLERO, A, CABALLERO I, JONES
I, JONES I, ASHBY I ASHBY I
BECKER I BECKER I BRADFORD
CIERTO CIERTO NO WAHAB. HI
WAHAB. AYE 5 TO 1. THAT BILL IS
OUT 5 TO 1 AB 2693. CHILDHOOD
SEXUAL ASSAULT STATUTE OF
LIMITATIONS DO PASS THIS IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE CABALLERO A
CABALLERO I JONES. NO. JONES NO.
ASHBY I ASHBY I BECKER BECKER I
BRADFORD. CIERTO CIERTO I WAHAB.
HI. WAHAB I. 5 TO 1 5 TO 1 THIS
THAT BILL IS OUT AB 3211.
PROVENANCE AUTHENTICITY AND
WATERMARKING STANDARDS. THIS IS
A DO PASS WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FOR MAYBE 2739. THE
BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2
WITH THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO
AND SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING
MEMBERS. WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON
TO ASSEMBLY MEMBER WILSON AB
2016 ONE SALES AND USE TAX
EXEMPTION ZERO EMISSION PUBLIC
TRANSPORTATION FERRIES. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS. WE'RE GOING
TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2063. THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH SENATOR
BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB 2229
PUPIL INSTRUCTION, MENSTRUAL
HEALTH EDUCATION DO PASS. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FOR MAYBE 2063. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
2319 CALIFORNIA DIGNITY AND
PREGNANCY AND CHILDBIRTH ACT.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS, AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
INCLUDE REQUIREMENTS RELATED TO
COURT IMPOSED PENALTY. WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2739. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH
THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
20. AB 3223 FOSTER YOUTH
SERVICES COORDINATING PROGRAM.
THIS IS A Dð PASS, WE'RE THAT'S
THE ACTION WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2063. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 6 TO 0 WITH SENATOR BRADFORD
NOT VOTING. MOVING ON TO
ASSEMBLY MEMBER WOULD AB 869
HOSPITALS. SEISMIC SAFETY. THE
ACTION IS Dð PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR. TO ADD
DISTRESSED HOSPITALS, WE'RE
GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL
CALL FROM AB 2063. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
2643. CANNABIS CULTIVATION.
ENVIRONMENTAL REMEDIATION. THE
ACTION IS DUE PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHOR, TO REDUCE
REQUIRED MEETINGS AND MAKE
CLARIFYING CHANGES. AND AGAIN,
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2063. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0, WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
2902 ORGANIC WASTE REDUCTION.
THE ACTION IS DUE PASS AS
AMENDED, PER THE AUTHOR, TO
STRIKE SOME COMPLIANCE OPTIONS
FOR CERTAIN JURISDICTIONS AS
WELL AS THE REQUIREMENT THAT
CALRECYCLE DEVELOP TRAINING AND
ASSISTANCE. WE'RE GOING TO
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2063. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 6 TO 0, WITH SENATOR BRADFORD
NOT VOTING AB 3129. HEALTH CARE
SYSTEMS CONSOLIDATION, THE
ACTION IS TO PASS, AS AMENDED,
TO REMOVE HOSPITALS AND
DERMATOLOGY MEDICAL GROUPS AND
MAKE OTHER CHANGES. THIS IS A
ROLL CALL VOTE. CABALLERO A
CABALLERO I JONES. NO. JONES NO.
ASHBY ASHBY I BECKER I BECKER I
BRADFORD. CIERTO CIERTO. NO.
WAHAB WAHHAB I 4 TO 2. THIS BILL
IS OUT 4 TO 2 3218. UNFLAVORED
TOBACCO LIST. THE ACTION IS DUE
PASS AS AMENDED PER THE AUTHOR
TO REVISE ENFORCEMENT
PROVISIONS. AGAIN THIS IS A ROLL
CALL CABALLERO I, CABALLERO I
JONES NO. JONES NO. ASHBY. ASHBY
I BECKER. BECKER I BRADFORD.
CIERTO NO. CIERTO. NO. WAHAB
WAHAB I 4 TO 2. BILL IS OUT 4 TO
2. AND IN CASE YOU HAVEN'T
NOTICED WE ARE ON THE ZS. SO
THAT IS REALLY GOOD NEWS. WE'RE
GOING TO START OFF BY I HAVE TO
ANNOUNCE THAT AB 2918 BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBERS OF BR HAS BEEN
HELD PER THE AUTHOR. AND THAT'S
THE ETHNIC STUDIES BILL. IT WAS
THAT HE HELD THE BILL HIMSELF.
WE'RE GOING TO MOVE ON TO AB
2258 HEALTH COVERAGE, COST
SHARING. THAT'S A DUE PASS. WHEN
A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM
AB 2739, THE BILL IS OUT ON A
VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AND SENATOR BRADFORD
NOT VOTING AB 2525. STATE
HIGHWAYS BÀN PROP PROPERTY
LEASES THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM AB 2739. THE BILL IS OUT ON
A VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH
REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
2613. RARE DISEASE ADVISORY
COUNCIL. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS.
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2063. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 6 TO 0 WITH
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
2704 IN-HOME SUPPORTIVE
SERVICES. THE ACTION IS DUE PASS
WHEN A SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL
FROM 2739 AB 2739. THE BILL IS
OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH
THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING AB
2889. LOCAL PUBLIC EMPLOYEE
RELATIONS, CITY OF LOS ANGELES
AND LOS ANGELES COUNTY. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2739. THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 4 TO 2, WITH THE REPUBLICANS
VOTING NO. AND SENATOR BRADFORD
NOT VOTING AB 2907 FIREARMS
RESTRAINED PERSON. THE ACTION IS
DUE PASS, AS AMENDED PER THE
AUTHOR, TO REQUIRE ARRESTING
OFFICERS TO ENSURE THAT ANY
FIREARM OR DEADLY WEAPON IN
PLAIN SIGHT ARE DISCOVERED
PURSUANT TO A SEARCH IS TAKEN
INTO TEMPORARY CUSTODY WHEN A
SUBSTITUTE THE ROLL CALL FROM AB
2063, THE BILL IS OUT ON A VOTE
OF 6 TO 0, WITH SENATOR BRADFORD
NOT VOTING. AND FINALLY AB 2917
FIREARMS RESTRAINING ORDER. THE
ACTION IS TO PASS AS AMENDED,
PER THE AUTHORED AND COAUTHORS
AND EXPAND THE GROUNDS ON WHICH
A COURT CAN ISSUE A GROW, AND
WE'RE GOING TO SUBSTITUTE THE
ROLL CALL FROM AB 2739. THE BILL
IS OUT ON A VOTE OF 4 TO 2, WITH
THE REPUBLICANS VOTING NO AND
SENATOR BRADFORD NOT VOTING. AND
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN, THAT
CONCLUDES OUR SUSPENSE FILE
AGENDA TODAY. SO REMEMBER THAT
WE WILL BE POSTING THE HEARING
RESULTS ON THE SENATE
APPROPRIATIONS COMMITTEE'S
WEBSITE. AND AN ADDENDUM
ANALYSIS WILL BE HOSTED SHORTLY
FOR ALL THE ITEMS THAT WERE
AMENDED TODAY. SO THE MEETING OF
THE SENATE COMMITTEE ON
APPROPRIATIONS IS ADJOURNED.
THANK YOU VERY MUCH FOR YOUR
PRESENTATIONS, FOR YOUR PRESENCE
HERE TODAY.